die tagelang wochenlang versuchen in ein
system einzudringen das klappt nicht ist
das frustrierend dabei wenn sie es dann
schaffen ist das ein unglaublicher kick
ein unglaublicher kick ist auch dieses
interview ich spreche mit lukas das ist
nicht sein echter name und sein gesicht
zeigen dürfen wir auch nicht denn seine
arbeit ist streng geheim
lukas ist cyber spionen beim
bundesnachrichtendienst den deutschen
geheimdienst fürs ausland
das darf aber niemand wissen und
entsprechend läuft unser treffen auch ab
wir dürfen kaum etwas film nicht wie wir
unsere handys wegschließen nicht wie wir
durch die sicherheitsschleusen gehen
lukas treffen wir schließlich in einem
abgelegenen raum die ganze zeit hinter
der kamera
der pressesprecher und ein
sicherheitsbeauftragter was genau machen
sie was genau ich tue kann ich im detail
natürlich jetzt nicht verraten aber im
prinzip gesagt ich bin hacker
das heißt ich dringe in it-systeme ein
um informationen zu beschaffen
klassische sachen wären dass man andere
länder aufklärt zum beispiel man
interessiert sich dafür was im land iks
oder y passiert eine andere variante
wäre man will wissen was ist mit waffen
und wehrtechnik im ausland was ist mit
organisierter kriminalität dann
natürlich was immer gut geht was ist mit
terrorismus das wird natürlich alles
felder wo auch hecking in irgendeiner
art und weise ausgeprägt gefragt ist
untersagt das als wäre es das
alltäglichste der welt
erst um die 30 jahre alt so viel verrät
er dass hecken hat er sich selbst
beigebracht
per initiativbewerbung kam er vor
einigen jahren zum bnd und macht seitdem
einen job von dem er niemandem etwas
erzählen darf
meistens sage ich ich mache die in
irgend einem amt das ich dann
vorschieben
und dann fragen die meisten auch schon
gar nicht mehr nach weil das klingt wie
drucker einrichten und das interessiert
niemanden
egal wo auf der welt zu jeder zeit
schlägt ein schmetterling mit seinen
flügeln und es kann etwas entstehen was
für uns eine bedeutung hat der bnd sucht
dringend nach leuten die mit it-systemen
noch geschickter umgehen können als der
klassische informatiker mit solchen pr
film will er sein image als arbeitgeber
aufpolieren
der nachrichtendienst steht dabei ein
harter konkurrenz zur privatwirtschaft
dort können die kandidaten deutlich mehr
verdienen das weiß auch der
pressesprecher
auf den ersten blick ist das ein klarer
wettbewerbsnachteil für den
bundesnachrichtendienst aber auch der
bundesnachrichtendienst versucht ein
attraktiver arbeitgeber zu sein klar
sagt der sprecher das aber was sagt
lukas warum es da hier weil ich hier die
dinge tun kann die ich da draußen so
nicht legal tun kann und b hat man schon
den eindruck dass man etwas getan hat
und am ende geht es in die
berichterstattung ein das hat
irgendetwas verändert es hat eben nicht
einfach nur bei irgendeiner firma
irgendwo einen haken gesetzt wir haben
einen sicherheitstest gemacht sondern es
hat eine außenpolitische konsequenz
gehabt und das ist ein output den finde
ich gut und da nehme ich auch weniger
geld in kauf zumal ich jetzt auch nicht
tot umfalle von dem gehalt das ich
verdiene
woanders zu arbeiten das könne er sich
zumindest im moment nicht vorstellen und
als beamter muss er das auch nicht es
sei denn seine tarnung fliegt auf mein
privates umfeld weiß im engeren umkreis
nähere verwandtschaft wo ich arbeite
bestimmte einzelne freunde wissen auch
wo ich arbeite aber darüber hinaus habe
ich bisher auch immer nur die resonanz
bekommen okay du arbeitest beim bnd ich
weiß du kannst nichts dazu sagen und
damit ist die sache erledigt
zu hause nie über erfolge oder frust im
job sprechen wie geht das
es ist in der tat schwierig zu hause gar
nicht über die arbeit reden zu können
inhaltlich das wusste ich vorher
das macht es nicht einfacher natürlich
aber ich kann damit leben und das bei
mir der fall ist dass ich mit 23
kollegen sehr gut befreundet bin kann
ich im zweifel auch mal in die büros
gehen und damit auskotzen wie man so
sagt es ist schon faszinierend diese
vorstellung ein doppelleben zu führen
dinge zu wissen die die öffentlichkeit
vielleicht nie erfahren wird ein
bisschen konnten spüren wie das ist aber
habe ich etwas wirklich überraschendes
gesehen nein
der bnd ist ein geheimdienst und der
sorgt schon dafür dass das was hinter
diesen mauern passiert vor allem eines
bleibt geheim